je vous donne mon avis également
la ministre comme ça vous aurez
l'occasion
à la fois de donner des éléments
d'éclaircissement donc en fait ce qui
continue de m'étonner je vous le dis
vous n'êtes jamais à l'origine de la
décision vous la prenez c'est votre
administration le cabinet ne vous alerte
pas vous dites j'ai pas de note ça
s'accélère oui il faut aller vite 4
jours après on décide
20 jours après la décision
est prise finalement ça ne nuit pas
c'est ce que j'en conclus c'est délai
très resserrés à la qualité de la
sélection aux procédures à respecter
pour avoir à la fois une transparence
des grilles d'analyse pour ensuite
pouvoir en toute connaissance de cause
avec un jury le plus averti possible
procéder à une sélection sachant
néanmoins
le président rénal l'a rappelé on voit
bien qu'il y a quand même dans les
acteurs qui travaillaient jusqu'à
maintenant
en bon intelligence avec le gouvernement
est dans le cadre du FIPD que certains
vont forcément être intéressés candidaté
c'est leur liberté voilà il y aura plus
ou moins de fléchages donc finalement
tout ça n'a pas mis cette accélération
ça peut-être même permis d'avoir une
meilleure qualité de réponse et d'être
plus performant avec une méthodologie
bien cadrée c'est ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui
monsieur le rapporteur moi je n'ai que
mon humble avis mais
bien sûr
plus dans la même responsabilité ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir des humbles agis
que je que je partage avec vous
aujourd'hui sur le nombre de dossiers
reçus
c'est mon troisième ministère ça fait
c'est ma septième année que j'exerce des
responsabilités ministérielles j'étais
adjointe au maire précédemment j'ai
aussi participé à de nombre ce qu'on
appelle un projet où j'en ai impulsé et
71 réponses pour un sujet par des
mémoire expression mais de niche c'est
important il ne s'agit pas là d'un appel
à projet auquel le tout venant peut
répondre il s'agit d'un appel à projet
qui s'adresse à des experts de la lutte
contre la radicalisation
spécifiquement sur les réseaux sociaux
ou en ligne donc on est 71 personnes
structures qui soient touchées et qui
répondent moi je trouve que c'est un
nombre important je ne vous dis pas que
tout a été bien fait parce qu'il est
documenté aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas
le cas donc bien sûr les choses auraient
pu être fait différemment mieux faites
et je disais tout à l'heure vos retours
d'expérience nous diront en quel sens
dans l'avenir nous pourrons mieux
ficeler cela mais à ce moment là bien
sûr c'est le cas je veux dire également
que ce que la façon monsieur rapporteur
dont vous présentez les choses laisse à
penser que je subirai les fesses sauf
votre espace sur l'interprétation de ce
que vous dites je rappelle là encore le
rôle de chacun
le ministre suit bien sûr les commandes
politiques et les dossiers qu'il a
impulsé auprès de l'administration mais
n'est pas là encore dans la mise en
oeuvre au jour le jour ou dans
l'ingénierie ce que veut savoir le
ministre c'est si ça avance si les
sujets débouche sont pris en main sont
traités si on est sur le ballon et pas
nécessairement quelle est la date de
rendu de la première étape des porteurs
de projets c'est en tout cas ma manière
de faire elle est peut-être pas bonne
mais en tout cas c'est la manière dont
je suis les choses à ce moment là